let's talk about this story we got here
from timcast.com supreme court justice
stephen breyer to retire the justice and
the bite administration have not yet
released a formal statement gensake did
say you know it's the prerogative of the
of the justice to retire when they feel
like it but uh i mean that's the story
stephen breyer is going to stay until
the end of the term
which just is uh when is that ending is
that ending in october i mean they
usually end the term in june sometimes
july but normally all the decisions are
done by the end of june oh okay june
june yeah all right so um
seems to me
that breyer who is considered a liberal
justice they're doing this because they
think they're going to be losing the
midterms
yeah they force briar out the left had
this really unprecedented campaign to
pressure biden excuse me to pressure
breyer to retire i guess there's another
campaign to pressure biden to retire
that's coming from all sides to be
honest uh but uh and breyer
had some interviews late last year or he
was out i think selling a book or he was
being interviewed and it was pretty
clear he had no interest in retiring and
something changed and they pressured him
and he left they bullied him off the
court
and you can bet the left that bullied a
sitting supreme court justice off the
court is going to demand that biden
point a appoint an extremist to to
replace him not a not a normal liberal
someone who's extreme well and and so
that's going to be the battle and you
know uh technically senate that you know
the senate can get someone passed for
biden or confirmed by biden if they get
50 plus one vote and we'll see what
happens and kamala would be the
tiebreaker i'd imagine we're going to
need trump unless she's the nominee if
we're going to save
and if
lindsey graham would vote for her you
know lindsey graham has voted for most
of the uh
judges put forward by biden at least in
in committing yeah like you were saying
how cancel culture can whip up a frenzy
so quick now it's like things can happen
so fast that
having someone in power for 50 years as
a supreme court justice is too dangerous
it doesn't make any sense anymore i
think we need term limits otherwise
we're going to get a 38 year old or a 42
year old that's going to think they're
going to be in power for 50 years
and then
i don't know you know i thought about
this an interesting question that you
know should we have a time limit for
justices or should it be a lifetime
appointment there's pros and cons
i i do like the idea that
you know when someone gets appointed it
kind of puts a pin in the cultural
perspective and says like you know this
person he's 45 he's going to be a
justice and he's going to be there for
40 years it kind of helps i think it's a
stabilizing force the the detriment
however is you get someone like you know
we had the supreme court justice who was
on his you know he was partially
comatose or whatever and he was just
like shaking in his bed and they're like
what do we do well he's a lifetime
appointment so right but i don't know
what what do you think you think we
should boot him out at a certain age or
something or you know i'm sympathetic to
that uh that i think the most the chief
concern is the quality of the judge and
his judicial philosophy so having a
judicial supremacist on the court who
wants to steal our liberty and steal our
self-governance and govern from the
bench if he's on the court for a year
that doesn't do us any good if he's on
the court for 10 years it doesn't do any
good but to have someone who defers to
the constitution and applies it as
written and originally understood
you know having them on the court for 30
years is fine the question is what is
the role of the court in our
constitutional system and it is it it's
outsized
you know we shouldn't be waiting waiting
with baited breath about how we're going
to govern ourselves on these core issues
every june
what's the court going to rule you know
the the court is one branch of our
government and
i'm against judicial supremacy and that
should be the big fight and i i would
expect that finally at least republicans
who share those views you know we can't
be approving judges just because the
president deserves there's his justice
no no no
the people deserve to have their rights
protected and not violated by justices
who think they know better than elected
representatives amen this this is
there are several uh laws and and
there's several rulings you go back they
just seem to be out right wrong
just on the face um i think
well
i'll i'll throw this one to you seamus
roe v wade yeah absolutely because the
big argument and and uh
is that it should be a legislative issue
not a court issue the court shouldn't be
legislating right
so break this down for me though i'm
just trying to highlight the issue
without getting too political on it but
uh the the big argument that we heard
from you know kavanaugh i think clarence
thomas uh when they were arguing the
mississippi abortion law they were like
why is this a court issue not a
legislative issue
well when you re i and i encourage
people to read supreme court opinions
because they're generally written for
public consumption and if you're you
know literate you can understand them
and uh the left is exposed when their
arguments are laid out there and when
you read rural versus wade you see it's
written like a piece of legislation it's
a perfect example of legislating from
the bench and it's not appropriate
abortion has been regulated by the
states you know for most of modern
history you know until you know
certainly once law once they started
talking about abortion they were
regulating and restricting it i know
there's arguments about the history but
it was a medical procedure and it was
regulated and there was no federal
jurisdiction over
making sure that abortion was in the con
of
protecting the abortion right it's not
part of the constitution
and and so you had the courts
uh certain courts uh in the supreme
court
justices who
agreed that women should have the right
to abortion and then they mistake they
mistook their policy preference for what
the constitution
requires and i talked about
you know i remember seeing judge pork
you know lose his nomination
and he wrote a book he called it the
tempting of america and the great
tempting for
the great temptation for judges is to
get on the bench
and impose your political views
and call it jurisprudence
so we one day after the show here a
while ago now almost a year and a half
ago
one of our friends that back at the old
studio uh nishra who's uh adam's wife
she
we we're all hanging out in the kitchen
and she's she's from sweden so she says
i have a question the your constitution
it says the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed and i'm like
right and she's like well why are they
banning guns and everyone starts
laughing just because it's like
someone who doesn't live in this country
could clearly see how broken the system
is and that it makes no sense and we all
laugh because we know we we know that
just legit legislating from the bench
uh and not and and not uh uh you know
the courts not properly ruling on our
rights it happens all of the time the
system just seems
it feels like we start with a good
foundation and now it's just like this
wonky jenga tower of random blocks stuck
in places because people wanted to you
know get something for themselves well
on the other hand things are going well
that's why the left is so upset about
the supreme court and they want to
expand it you had last week
you know you had nina totenberg defame
and smear judge gorsuch
jane mayer of the new yorker went after
justice thomas and his wife afterwards
you're going after his wife to get at
justice thomas you've had this pressure
campaign on breyer and i keep on talking
about all our institutions being under
assault they're trying to blow up the
supreme court
uh with this court packing scheme so
that briar
breyer leaving is you know he's he's a
liberal he'll probably be replaced with
a liberal but the goal is to pack the
court
and negate the conservative voices on
the court that now are rising and
dominating yeah i mean
the i think the populist view is that
roberts is not
conservative and that you know uh
kavanaugh hasn't actually done a pretty
a decent job or anything like that but i
don't think they're going to replace
briar with a liberal i think they're
going to replace him with a marxist or
something like that
yeah well we'll see what uh senator
manchin has to say about it yeah yeah
but i i you know yes mansion and maybe
cinema because they've they've stood you
know they've you know resisted the
democratic party's whims
but you still have some republicans who
are going to be like now now we got to
be accommodating and fair
but it's an election year so so i think
uh
it will be
there's a greater chance that
republicans will be unified against a
extremist nominee and it depends who the
nominee is
well biden says it's going to be a black
woman
well again
so now joe biden has announced that no
male need apply no white person need
apply yeah how is that legal can you
guys i mean would you guys sue him over
that i don't think you can sue him over
that i don't think so
but that's
i mean it's it's so weird that we're at
this point in this country i mean i
always want to sue over everything and
yeah and the lawyers say well you can
you won't succeed yeah you know what the
saying is you can sue a ham sandwich
another world leader that uh was
obsessed with appointing um a specific
kind of creature to uh the their role
was uh caligula who appointed uh the
roman emperor the inbred roman emperor
who appointed his horse to be a
chancellor uh when you but it wasn't
that he was insulting them yeah he was
like making a mockery of the system but
this is different also yeah this is
racial identitarianism it's insanity our
president it's it's for our supreme
court well it's the same thing with his
vp nominee and it's hilarious because he
chose kamala harris essentially to
pander to progressives because he
pigeonholed himself he said i have to
pick a woman of color and basically
every progressive i know hates kamala
harris so it's beautiful and i can only
hope that they will hate his supreme
court nominee just as much but of course
i'm sure that i wouldn't like them
either the way the democratic party has
been going in the past couple years i
wouldn't be surprised if biden chooses
the most absurd
hated person
establishment and all the progressives
start screaming and then the democratic
senators are like if i vote for this i'm
gonna lose so
i mean whoever he picks like it is going
to be horrible it's going to be a
horrible thing
whoever he picks like we're waiting for
daddy to make a move it's so gross how
does this one dude get to pick it's
called the president's gonna make the
decision the constitution gives them the
right to appoint the judge and the
senate has to provide consent and so an
advice and consent is the term is so
there is a there is a check in place and
uh it's going to be close run thing i
mean typically
you know if mitch if mitch mcconnell
were in the majority there'd be no doubt
the nominee would get through
my view is chuck schumer has been an
awful leader for the democrats uh he's
been dragged around by aoc and the left
and he's lost control of the senate and
so i i think
the president's nominee
that otherwise might be able to squeak
through might be stopped because of of
uh
the craziness in our politics right now
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you